bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 1er février accord politique en
cours entre conservateurs et parti
libéral d'extrême droite en autriche qui
doit finaliser ce soir la volonté
européenne de geler tout contact
officiel bilatéraux est jugée
disproportionnée et injuste en autriche
questions sur ce thème à hubert védrine
minisère étrangères dans quelques nick
notre avis premier jour de l'application
officielle de la deuxième loi sur la
réduction du temps de travail à 35
heures plusieurs mouvements de grève et
un constat sur les emplois créés des
négociations en cours
les chasseurs défi la réglementation
européenne au lendemain de la date de
fermeture de la chasse aux oiseaux
migrateurs selon la réglementation en
europe une semaine consacrée aux moyens
de lutte contre le cancer un plan
gouvernemental vient d'être annoncée
nous évoquerons les relations entre les
malades et le milieu hospitalier avec
des témoignages
a lyon un succès inattendu de librairies
mémoire d'un paysan breton à partir des
cahiers rédigé entre 1850 et 1950 par le
fils d'un journalier agricole libre
penseur et grand voyageur l'extrême
droite autrichienne et son leader yoga
leader chef du parti libéral sensible à
quelques théories nazies est donc prête
sans doute d'ici la fin de cette soirée
à gouverner en compagnie des
conservateurs l'annoncent pour en être
faite depuis vienne ce soir les deux
parties sont en train de se mettre
d'accord sans tenir compte donc des
avertissements étrangers des menaces
américaines encore formulé ce soir et de
la volonté des 14 pays membres de
l'union européenne de rompre toute
relation guéret terral en ce cas injuste
et disproportionnée c'est ainsi que bon
nombre d'autrichiens réagissait après
l'annnonce de cette volonté des
partenaires européens d'isoler leurs
pays patrice romedenne et gilles jacquet
ont utilisé le bal des chasseurs qui a
lieu chaque année dans l'un des palais
viennois pour écouter quelques unes des
3500 personnes venus se divertir parmi
elles your right there lui-même
crise politique peut couver l'europe
durcir le ton vienne n'en demeure pas
moins fidèle en cette saison des bals à
ce qui fait son charme
une des traditions fait sienne
certainement qui a pu se répandre
partout dans le monde
et cette valse est un passe de musique
et non pas
on ne change pas non plus sur la
conscience des gens et vous me trouverez
personne pour vous dire le contraire
dans cette foule où se mêlent socialiste
conservateur au provider mais où
curieusement les discours se rejoignent
faire pression c'est cela qui n'est pas
démocratique 17 heures certains hommes
politiques européens jusqu'à leader
n'est pas un démocrate mais au fond
c'est ce qu'il demande à l'autriche qui
n'est pas démocratique
parce que la démocratie cela signifie
que le pouvoir appartient aux gens et
non pas aux pays étrangers
avoir peur mais pourquoi donner moins de
raison d'avoir peur de riders une raison
d'avoir peur de cette aube york haider
un parmi trois mille danseurs une raison
de craindre un homme dont les dérapages
verbaux sur l'immigration le troisième
reich sont considérés ici comme des
erreurs de jeunesse et y être l'objet il
s'était excusé ça casse c'est aussi et
il ya cinq ans alors qu'on en finisse
gaspiller une raison une seule une
raison d'avoir peur d'un père de famille
qui parle si bien de démocratie alors si
je comprends bien
chaque autrichiens devraient demander ce
qu'il doit faire
à paris ou à bruxelles ça ça n'arrivera
pas tant que j'aurai assez d'énergie
pour sauver la démocratie en autriche
monsieur leader tient un discours
populiste analyse cette jeune femme qui
vote elle pour les conservateurs je
pense que l'autriche en ce moment manque
de personnalité politique suffisamment
forte
il y a comme un vide et monsieur haider
bâti son succès là dessus mais vous dire
ont-ils les urnes se sont exprimés il
convient d'en respecter le verdict pour
le reste vive la polka
et après la danse le tournis des
négociations palais présidentiel à
vienne où le président que les styles a
reçu monsieur wolfgang schüssel le
président du parti conservateur monsieur
victor climat et puis pendant ce temps
là en tractations entre partis
conservateur et le parti libéral
d'extrême droite de jörg haider des
négociations pour former ce gouvernement
l'annnonce de la formation de cette
coalition a été repoussée plusieurs fois
depuis 18 heures on l'attend d'ici ce
soir cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale à paris lionel jospin commenté
la pression européenne sur l'autriche au
nom de principes et de valeurs
humanistes
l'objectif est de faire en sorte que
montrent une prise de conscience en
autriche et que ce projet soit
interrompu s'il n'en était pas ainsi
monsieur le député croyez bien qu en
contact avec nos partenaires européens
le gouvernement français serait amenée
sur la base de ce qui a été décidé sur
la base de nouvelles propositions qu'il
pourrait faire notamment s'il était
confronté à cette situation pendant la
présidence française à prendre toutes
mesures pour que l'autriche de monsieur
haider échoue seul chouette alors
politiquement isolé en europe
hormis d'autres actions politiques celle
du président du groupe udf il dit
philippe douste blazy qui refusent au
sein du parti populaire européen qu'ils
ont représenté à l'assemblée strasbourg
un parti conservateur celui de monsieur
sous sol qui aurait passé alliance dit
il avec l'extrême droite
en revanche jean marie le pen dénonce l'
ultimatum totalitaire des européens à
l'autriche
la tonalité des propos du président de
la commission européenne romano prodi
est assez différente de celle du premier
ministre portugais monsieur pires au nom
de l'union européenne tout en partageant
les inquiétudes des états membres le
seul critère que la commission utilisera
pour évaluer la situation at il dit en
autriche sont des décisions concrètes du
programme du gouvernement constitué des
conservateurs et de l'extrême droite
propose donc de monsieur mono produit le
président la commission européenne lui a
dream bonsoir est ce que tout cela n'est
pas un délit d'ingérence vis-à-vis d'un
pays qui est une république démocratique
je suppose que le considérer comme tel
est-ce que nous avons le droit de nous
ingérer dans un résultat électoral mais
il n'y a pas de doute sur le caractère
démocratique de l'autriche et les
autrichiens ont voté librement pour ce
résultat qui dès octobre pouvaient
inquiéter d'ailleurs je vais bien au
club j'avais dit que si l'autriche céder
à la tentation de cette coalition elle
se mettrait d'elle-même dans une
situation déplorable mais il faut
distinguer appartement ou l'autriche a
voulu entrer dans l'union européenne ce
que rappelait le premier mis cet après
midi à l'assemblée elle a souscrit à un
programme un projet une ambition c'est
pas simplement une association d'états
qui sont là pour eux gérer des affaires
économiques à un projet politique et on
trouve d'ailleurs dans les textes qui
nous lient les traités qui vous unissent
le traité de maastricht modifier des
articles notamment l'article 6 qui
définissent la démocratie les droits de
l'homme la conception européenne c'est à
dire ce que nous disons pays candidats
ils doivent d'abord être en mesure de
respecter sa de reprendre ce que nous
appelons les acquis ce sera lundi en
turquie notamment
c'est ce que ces scandinaves turquie à
tel point que même si nous avons reconnu
le fait de la candidature turque ne
devons pas ouvert les négociations qu
avec la turquie
il faudra une autre décision pour mieux
les négociations la commande comprend
bien on l'essayé à 27 kcal/100 g luc
thoral qui votent pour le parti de said
heures
d'une certaine manière on est bien
obligé de respecter cet électorat oui
mais on peut au mal droit et je crois
qu'on a le devoir de dire comme on l'a
dit ces derniers jouent avec beaucoup de
netteté beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup
d'indignation
on a le droit de dire aux responsables
autrichiens d'une part responsables
politiques ceux qui vont rendre possible
peut-être cette coalition et d'autre
part aux électeurs autrichien qui se
sont fourvoyés dans ce vote
on a le droit de dire l'autriche c'est
une chose mais vous êtes engagés dans un
progrès qui vous dépasse un projet qui
est un projet fait ensemble et nous
avons là des valeurs de démocratie de
droits de l'homme que bafoue
manifestement et que contredit les idées
et l'orientation générale du parti
d'extrême - et si les traînées seconde
crippa loignon certainement qu'il vient
de faire une annonce que d'autres et là
vous avez des connaissances qu'il
fallait mettre l'autriche surveillance
très étroite au cas où ce gouvernement
serait formé et puis maintenant on a
passé un cap
c'est un tricheur au jeu avant même que
jamais cela constitue je n'ai pas dit
que ça c'est dire que dans un premier
temps c'est l'expression d'une aversion
pour les idées véhiculées par ce parti
populiste d'extrême droite une
réprobation pour les décisions du parti
conservateur qui prendrait cette
coalition possible
ça c'est ce que nous avons fait jusqu'à
ce soir c'est avec beaucoup de force et
les idées lancées notamment par la
france ont été reprises c'est un fête
importante pour l'heure leur politique
l'europe comme projet politique et
morale comme projet de société comme
projet humaniste ces idées ont été
reprises tout de suite qui va dire quoi
l'autriche a sa place dans l'union
européenne ça a eu envie d'être était la
personne ne peut dire en mai c'est en
classe 1 ses principes mais sur le plan
bilatéral sur le plan des relations
entre nous et ses éventuelles futures
c'est encore un éventuel futur
gouvernement
nous avons le droit de modifier
d'adapter nos relations à ce que nous
ressentons
étant donné ce que nous ressentons par
rapport à ce dont est porteur ce
programme et ce projet nous allons
ramener des relations bilatérales au
plus strict lieu au plus bas niveau
possible
vous avez peut-être entendu ce matin
leur prépa j'ai commun que nous avons le
droit de dire ça entendu ce matin
l'ambassadeur d'autriche en france
francesca qui dit en ayant cette
situation-là cette position-là l'europe
renforce monsieur haider effectivement
les sondages lui donnent maintenant plus
de 33 % peut-être encore plus est ce
qu'on n'est pas en train de faire son
jeu
oui mais est-ce qu on retourne dans la
proposition sous prétexte que je
pourrais le renforcer parce que les
populismes on les connaît ils se
nourrissent de tout mécontentement et
les protestations
est ce qu'il faudrait ne rien dire faire
comme si de rien n'était faire comme si
c'était un vote comme un autre c'est pas
possible
et c'est pas la position qui a été
retenue par les grands dirigeants
européens et je crois que tous ceux qui
attendent des positions fortes de
l'europe doivent être fier ce soir à la
façon dont l'europe en tout cas des 14
pays d'europe ont réagi par rapport à ça
maintenant si ce gouvernement se réalise
malgré tout se concrétise
alors il sera comme je l'indiqué très
récemment il sera placé sur une sorte de
surveillance constante
étant donné les engagements qu'il a lui
même prisme l'autriche le payer
en tant qu'etat donc nous surveillerons
à partir de l'article 6 du traité qui
définit la démocratie à l'européenne et
l'article 7 qui prévoit les procédures
de suspension de vote qu'on peut engager
si il y à un manquement répétées et
constant à ses principes
nous surveillons tout ce qui se passera
en autriche donc voyez le rapport à
ingérence et souveraineté on est dans
une situation qui mêle les deux
situations nous avons une sorte de droit
moral de porter une appréciation sauf
qu'ils se passent par le ce des
partenaires aussi proche et nous devions
lancer cet avertissement aux autrichiens
tout cela renforce le camp des
souverainistes noms de ceux qui pensent
qu'il ya trop d'europe et que au fond
les états ne peuvent plus rien décider
eux mêmes mais l'autriche a voulu entrer
dans l'union européenne
elle fait partie de trois pays qui sont
entrés qu'en leur union européenne est
passée de 12 à 15
elle a souscrit non seulement à des
arrangements type politique agricole
commune au fonds structurels mais aussi
à des projets lé prochain un projet
commun une valeur et si le rap et
cherche à jouer un rôle utile dans le
monde pour que le monde soit meilleur
mieux régulé que la démocratie et
progrès se stabilise
c'est aussi parce que e elt ans
représente elle-même quelque chose donc
il ya une cohérence entre ce qu'elle est
elle même et les les conseils qu'elle
essaie de donner aux autres les
autrichiens sont entrés dans cette union
européenne la en connaissance de cause
et comme il semble oublier certains
d'entre eux bien sûr fout pas précisé le
nombre des autrichiens mais ce que nous
y en a beaucoup qui sont tout à fait
désolé de cet engrenage et nous avons le
droit de leur rappeler et nous avons le
droit de prendre des dispositions de
vigilance toute particulière si ce
gouvernement se met en place
merci bien védrine en tchétchénie il est
temps que cela cesse s'estimait
aujourd'hui la secrétaire d'état
américaine madeleine albright en lançant
un nouvel appel à la fin des opérations
militaires plusieurs informations
contradictoires ont fait état de
l'abandon par le tchétchène de la
capitale grozny et des blessures
infligées au président de la république
tchétchène
depuis moscou le commentaire de notre
correspondant gilles rabin il a peur et
il a raison car en dur de combat pour
arriver là quand vient l'heure de
planter le drapeau russe au coeur de
grozny l'emblème n'est pas glorieux
c'était hier soir peu avant la tombée de
la nuit l'armée russe venait enfin de
prendre la place minutes cas le centre
de la ville rebelle l'état des hommes et
des blindés témoignaient de la violence
des combats
déjà lors de la première guerre la place
minutes cas c'était le dernier bastion
la dernière poche de résistance avant la
chute de la vie ce matin des combattants
tchétchènes semblaient avoir disparu
ils ont affirmé avoir réussi à quitter
la ville dans la nuit les russes ont
démenti il se méfie des petites chaînes
pour la guerre comme des professionnels
j'ai essayé de sortir un copain blessés
leurs tireurs m'empêchait d'avancer même
d'un mètre et demi après quatre mois de
bombardements intensifs la ville
n'existe plus l'armée russe a conquis un
tas de ruines
et cette conquête ces soldats l'ont payé
au prix fort 1200 hommes tués bilan
officiel trois fois plus 3000 selon les
mères de soldats
toutes les maisons tous les immeubles
dont tous les quartiers ont été
transformé en forteresse et bourré de
mines et d'explosifs face à l'armée
russe le tchétchène ont réussi à tenir
quarante jours mais malgré l'incroyable
réseau de bonne guerre de tranchées de
base d'attaqué de repli ils ont essuyé
de lourdes pertes
chamil bassaïev le plus prestigieux de
leurs chefs de guerre est l'ennemi
numéro 1 des russes auraient été
grièvement blessé et amputé d'une jambe
selon plusieurs témoignages
l'information qui n'a pas été confirmée
elle non plus ni par les deux chaînes ni
par les russes ce mardi 1er février
marquait l'entrée en application
officielle de la nouvelle loi sur les 35
heures c'était aussi la date choisie par
cinq syndicats de la ratp pour lancer
une grève fin de réclamer une véritable
réduction du temps de travail la
création d'emplois des hausses de
salaires et l'amélioration des
conditions des employés de la régie le
mouvement a très sérieusement perturbé
le trafic sans toutefois le paralyser la
journée fut donc difficile mais un peu
moins que prévu pour les usagers
parisiens commentaires florence griffon
ils ont choisi le métro malgré des
prévisions plutôt pessimistes
trafic quasi nul sur la ligne 6 et sur
la ligne 8 bref vivement que la journée
se termine
charles de gaulle à montparnasse à pied
durée 1h et ce soir et ce soir idem si
le métro n'arrive pas ça va être idem
notre sens qui servent aux poches change
vraiment fusée les poches prendre une
autre direction
j'ai 1 pouces qui fonctionne bien donc
heureux surprise le métro tant attendu
arrive enfin
signe d'une amélioration visible
également à l'extérieur les bus et même
les taxis à temps de leurs clients il
n'y a pas beaucoup de boulot aujourd'hui
1 confirmant que l'on aurait pu penser
pourtant ce matin c'était l'ambiance des
grands jours de grève la plupart des
métros fonctionnaient au ralenti
en tout - d'une rame sur deux même
constat pour les rer
les usagers ont piétiné ferme quand la
ratp ou la sncf est en grève on a
l'habitude
voilà pour prendre sa photo il pouvait
sourire maintenant l'habitude aussi de
jouer des coudes
mais pour les non-initiés c'était un peu
plus difficile
le board of même pas traîner pas
décevoir le seul fait cuire les bus se
sont également fait désirer moins d'un
sur deux en service et une attente qui
fait ternie
deux mineurs une demi heure trois quarts
d'heure pas grave
j'aime ça va il m'a dit quand tu veux
j'y vais
seule valeur sûre ce soir comme pour
toute la journée le train de banlieue ce
qui était aujourd'hui désorienté
retrouveront demain leurs habitudes
d'autres grèves ont affecté les
transports publics à lorient
saint-etienne reims chambéry toulouse
encore et puis à marseille plusieurs
milliers de personnes ont défilé dans
deux cortèges distincts toujours avec
les mêmes revendications élargi au
pouvoir d'achat et de retraite
et puis des poids lourds ont bloqué le
centre de la ville de marseille
plusieurs heures cette multiplication de
grève a été relativisée par madame aubry
mais pour les débuts officiels de
l'entrée en vigueur des 35 heures pour
les entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
si l'on fait les comptes il y a encore
beaucoup beaucoup d'accords a signé
quant aux emplois directement créés par
les 35 heures les statistiques prête à
discussion explications avec mary pierce
amitié difficile de mettre toutes les
pendules à la même heure seulement 20%
des entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
ont réduit le temps de travail
ce qui signifie que seul un tiers des
salariés bénéficient aujourd'hui des 35
heures légales
or selon le ministère de l'emploi et de
la solidarité
ces accords ont permis la création ou la
sauvegarde de 160 mille emplois alors
que va-t-il se passer pour les
entreprises restées aux 39 heures
cette année la loi prévoit que les
heures supplémentaires soit majorée de
10%
mais si aucun accord n'est signé avec
les salariés un repos compensateur de
deux jours et demi par an doit leur être
accordé mais attention au 1er janvier
2001 cette majoration des heures
supplémentaires passera à 25 % pour
inciter les entreprises à signer un
accord avant cette date
enfin pour les entreprises de moins de
20 salariés la loi prévoit que les
accords soient signés avant le 1er
janvier 2002 parmi les entreprises qui
n'ont pas signé encore yann fronty
christian galley parce qu'elle paiera
nous présente maintenant une banque
familiale installée à orthez dans le
béarn cette banque emploie une trentaine
de salariés qui ne bénéficient donc
toujours pas de 35 heures il est vrai
que le cadre juridique dans tout le
secteur bancaire est encore assez flou
l'eau continuera de couler sous les
ponts le tourbillon sociale n'aura pas
lieu
pourtant cette journée aurait pu être
historique mais à orthez comme ailleurs
le passage aux 35 heures n'aura en rien
modifié les habitudes
exemple avec cette petite banque
familiale la réduction du temps de
travail est en principe effective depuis
aujourd'hui
mais ici tout cela reste bien théorique
vous êtes au courant qu aujourd'hui en
face aux 35 heures oui j'ai entendu oui
j'ai entendu vaguement mais bon on va
pas refaire le monde ici je sais pas
très bien comment ça va se passer je ne
sais pas on a quelques informations mais
on n'a pas commencé à travailler là
dessus au niveau de l'établissement
manque je ne sais pas je sais pas en
plus il ya des signes et des différences
entre les cadres et non cadres
donc ce niveau là pour l'instant toutes
les portes sont ouvertes
le chantier social repoussée il faut
dire que le contexte n'a rien d'évident
une convention collective tout juste
renégocié dans le secteur bancaire des
mois de croissance qui débouche sur une
activité stabilisée pour cet
établissement
pas facile de passer aux 35 heures dans
ces conditions le pdg a donc préféré
remettre ça à plus tard
quitte à payer ce choix
ça va nous coûter à peu près 1% de la
masse salariale c'est-à-dire à peu près
200 mille francs
deux cent mille francs pour cette année
2000 et si tenté que nous ne soyons pas
passer en demi heure alors ça représente
à peu près 500 mille francs
mais les salariés ne toucheront pas
forcément un chèque ce que ce pdg ne
sait pas c'est que la loi aubry lui
permet de transformer la majoration des
heures supplémentaires en repos
compensateur deux journées et demie pour
l'année 2001 rien de très pénalisant les
35 heures vont donc se mettre en place
progressivement
ici la négociation n'a pas encore
commencé même si tout le monde avoue
vouloir s'y mettre très rapidement
en sus de toutes ces grèves et
manifestations autour des 35 heures il y
avait pour la deuxième journée
consécutive plusieurs dizaines de
barrages routiers à l'initiative des
chauffeurs la majorité des barrages ont
été levés après quelques heures de
négociations au ministère des transports
avec jean claude gayssot
mais cette levée provoque la discorde au
sein des organisations syndicales rejet
politique il se cache un général de
force ouvrière accuse la cgt et la cfdt
de trahison et de lâchage lamentable
commentaires émilie heymans
on va dégager progressivement le mot
d'ordre est donné
les la levée des barrages laisse un
certain goût amer la crainte de perdre
de l'argent avec les 35 heures
timour faux ongles ou même un tapis
comme d'habitude on a procédé à la case
départ c'est la cfdt la première qui a
annoncé la levée des barrages c'est
aussi la première à plier bagage force
ouvrière elle tient encore une dizaine
de barrages notamment dans la région de
bordeaux elle fo estime que les
garanties apportées par le ministre des
transports sont insuffisants après
quatre heures de discussions cet
après-midi les routiers ont obtenu des
avancées concernant les temps de coupure
et les heures de nuit un observatoire
chargé de vérifier la bonne application
de la réduction du temps de travail est
également créée il ya un peu plus de
concret bien que sur la question des
salaires on puisse pas dire aujourd'hui
qu'on ait abouti
c'est là qu'un engagement mais il était
clair que le ministre ne veut pas aller
beaucoup plus loin
les salaires justement il est prévu que
les syndicats de routiers en discute
avec les patrons dès la semaine
prochaine
il paraît qu'ils ont pour les avancées
sociales maintenant la balle est dans
leur camp et on les attend avec des
propositions sérieuses qui ont été
formulées cette semaine dans le conflit
rendez vous le 8 février pour des
négociations paritaires sur les salaires
et les horaires de travail
selon la réglementation européenne la
chasse aux oiseaux migrateurs est fermé
depuis minuit mais les chasseurs
militants du mouvement chasse pêche
nature et traditions ne l'entendent pas
de cette oreille ils en ont fait la
démonstration dans la somme notamment
aujourd'hui toujours en guerre contre la
ministre de l'environnement qu'il
baptise plutôt trivialement la voynet il
en appelle au premier ministre contre
les règles européennes dont la france
est signataire
avant l'aube la mobilisation des
chasseurs de la somme était déjà forte
comme l'ont constaté jean michel
carpentier michel levasseur
voilà le canard ça se chassent la nuit
ici à l'affût dans une lutte de picardie
sur l'étang des tourbes car dans ce pays
pauvre
on s'est longtemps chauffée à la tourbe
depuis ce matin la suite d'une directive
européenne
la chasse est interdite dans toute la
région mais les militants de cpnt chasse
pêche nature et traditions refuse cette
situation est proche dans l'illégalité
je chasserai jusqu'au 28 février son
être un braconnier pourquoi je serais un
braconnier alors que la loi française a
autorisé l'an dernier à chasser jusqu'au
28 donc je ne me considère pas du tout
en infraction aujourd'hui mais le
tribunal a interdit de chasser en
février dans la somme le fief de cpnt
à la base il n'en fallait pas plus pour
convoquer la presse
visite guidée jean saint-josse accueille
le communiste local maxime gremetz
les troupes sont bien chaude
le patron des chasseurs tirent à vue à
partir des propos de madame voynet hier
qui a dit des saloperies et des
mensonges
c'était le cas encore montée d'un cran
j'ai été obligé au long de cpnt en votre
nom à tous aujourd'hui de demander au
premier ministre de la calmer parce que
j allais si elle allait vers il faut
qu'elle prenne le vermifuge un discours
d'autant plus brutale qu il camoufle une
supplique au crêt de lionel jospin
aujourd'hui on appelle au premier
ministre pour lui demander de trouver un
moratoire pour calmer les esprits sur
les terres et apaisé après la chasse il
faut ramener à terre les canards attaché
dans l'eau pour attirer les autres une
scène désormais interdite jusqu'à
l'automne prochain à moins d'un geste du
premier ministre
les chasseurs français aux oiseaux
migrateurs aquatiques ou terrestres
comme ceux là peuvent donc être
considérés légalement comme des
braconniers mais pour être précis faut
bien reconnaître que la réglementation
de la chasse en europe est plutôt
disparates
l'explication hélène dernier nous sommes
au coeur des marais de charente maritime
pour ces chasseurs ce sont les dernières
cartouches tirées contre les canards et
autres oiseaux migrateurs dans 30
départements français les préfets ont
décidé d'interdire la chasse aux oiseaux
migrateurs
à partir d'aujourd'hui 1er février dans
ces départements
si la chasse est pratiquée c'est donc en
toute illégalité
partout ailleurs on peut encore tirer
quelques espèces
la loi française de 1998 autorise la
chasse jusqu'au 28 février
mais en décembre dernier le conseil
d'état a jugé cette loi incompatible
avec la directive européenne une
victoire pour les protecteurs de la
nature
cette année surtout les tribunaux saisis
par les écologistes
seuls deux les ont débouté la france se
fait donc encore une fois remarquer en
grèce au portugal
on chasse en moyenne cinq à six mois
dans l'année trois mois et demi en
espagne et sauf exception la chasse
s'arrête le 31 janvier en
grande-bretagne en belgique et au
danemark la france totalise la période
de chasse la plus longue jusqu'à sept
mois et demi et fait figure de mauvais
élève au sein de l'union européenne
a lyon la mise en examen pour recel
d'abus de biens sociaux d'henri chabert
le député rpr provoque un début de
bouleversements politiques
henry chabert qui est candidat à la
succession de raymond burr parle d'un
complot politico judiciaire ses
fonctions d'adjoint à l'urbanisme de la
ville de lyon ont été suspendus
reportage à lyon benoît gadret olivier
jacquelin à en croire les sondages le
rpr henry chabert partait favori dans la
course à la mairie de lyon
mais sa candidature a désormais lesté
d'un lourd handicap
une mise en examen pour recel d'abus de
biens sociaux
derrière cette affaire c'est d'abord une
affaire politique qui est engagée depuis
maintenant 11 ans henry chabert est en
charge à lyon des affaires d'urbanisme
à ce titre ce proche de michel noir est
en relation très étroite avec des
entrepreneurs
la justice s'interroge sur les travaux
réalisés dans la maison de campagne du
député travaux qui n'auraient pas été
payées à leur juste valeur
de même de sérieux doutes existent quant
au financement par ces entreprises du
bâtiment d'une association présidée par
henry chabert ces accusations constitue
aux yeux du député un complot politico
judiciaire fomenté à l'hôtel de ville
j'ose dire que la mairie ont pas le
maire lui-même sur le nom je fais la
distinction mais la mairie n'a pas été
tout à fait étrangère la manière dont
les choses ont été en permanence piloter
particulièrement visé le premier adjoint
udf christian philip que l'on présente
comme le dauphin de raymond barre
philippe et chabbert appartiennent à la
majorité municipale mais depuis
plusieurs mois la guerre est déclarée
sous le regard impuissant du maire en
partance raymond barre totalement
divisée aux prises une fois encore avec
la justice
la droite est aujourd'hui menacée dans
l'un de ses fiefs historiques condamné à
un an d'inéligibilité le président du
front national jean marie le pen
pourrait perdre du même poussé mandat de
député européen et de conseiller
régional de provence alpes côte d'azur
monsieur le pen n'entend pas se
soumettre
d'autant que les décrets et arrêtés
officielles nécessaires n'ont toujours
pas été signés enquête arnaud boutet et
frédéric basket
les faits remontent à la campagne des
législatives en 1997
ce jour là dans les rues de mantes la
jolie jean-marie le pen agresse une élue
socialiste condamné à un an
d'inéligibilité
le président du front national peut-il
aujourd'hui conserver ses mandats de
conseiller régional en région paca et
surtout de député européen lui pense que
c'est possible puisque dans son arrêt la
cour d'appel se borne à interdire aux
candidats le pen de se présenter à toute
élection pendant 12 mois la cour d'appel
sans doute pour préciser encore la chose
à bienne est établi dans son arrêt que
la perte de l'éligibilité au annonce
qu'elle va infliger virgule était
limitée à l'éligibilité aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée de strasbourg nicole
fontaine la présidente répète qu'elle ne
peut fermer les portes du parlement aux
députés le père cette décision
appartient aujourd'hui à ti au
gouvernement français c'est très clair
le code électoral français des élections
européennes précise l'inéligibilité
lorsqu'elle survient en cours de mandat
met fin à celui ci la constatation en
est effectué par décret concernant les
élections régionales tous conseillers
qui se trouve dans un cas
d'inéligibilité est déclaré
démissionnaire d'office par arrêté du
représentant de l'état dans la région
pour les avocats qui ont combattu jean
marie le pen dans la sphère de mantes la
jolie
il y a urgence le droit électoral doit
s'appliquer
monsieur le pen reste électeurs il
conserve le droit de témoigner en
justice
mais s'il n'est plus éligible et donc de
ce fait doit nécessairement perdre ses
mandats toute autre solution serait une
atteinte à l'état de droit extrêmement
draps le parlement de strasbourg a connu
un seul précédent 1996 avec bernard
tapie les lui avait démissionné s'il se
voit privé de ses mandats jean-marie le
pen qu'on saisir le conseil d'état et
jouèrent une nouvelle fois le martyre de
la classe politique
voilà peut-être pourquoi le gouvernement
semble hésiter à le sanctionner toute
cette semaine l'actualité médicale
tournera autour du cancer un congrès
réuni à paris les plus grands
spécialistes mondiaux venus faire le
point sur les derniers progrès
thérapeutique et en fin d'après-midi le
gouvernement a annoncé un programme de
lutte contre le cancer avec pour
objectif de réduire de 20% le nombre de
fumeurs de buveurs excessifs et de
malades dépendants de l'alcool
en france 700 mille personnes sont
porteuses un cancer et chaque année 250
mille nouveaux cas sont diagnostiqués il
ya près de cent quarante huit mille
décès dus au cancer chaque année en
france
en dehors de l'aspect médical du
traitement contre le cancer il faut
aussi prendre en compte l'aspect
psychologique et l'accueil des malades
voici avec le reportage de france oswald
est le témoignage d'une femme atteinte
par cette maladie qui a voulu aussi se
battre contre l' isolement dont sont
souvent victimes des patients c'est au
centre léon bérard à lyon il y a dix ans
quand elle a appris qu'elle avait une
tumeur régime entrait dans ce que l'on
appelait alors le pavillon anticancéreux
aujourd'hui grâce à elle si
l'association les choses ont bien changé
espace coiffure salon convivial salle de
gymnastique
il fallait à tout prix préserver la
morale des patients voulu travailler sur
certains points qui n'était pas encore
mis en exergue en particulier considérer
la personne humaine comme un être humain
à part entière porteur d'une maladie
mais cette maladie n'occulte ni sa
sensibilité ni son intelligence et je
crois que nous avons porté toute notre
attention sur les bleus à l'âme
améliorer les conditions de vie des
malades c'est l'un des objectifs du plan
annoncé par le ministère de la santé
toute une série de mesures est prévue
pour faire reculer la maladie me nouveau
matters réalisés dont il s'agit de
renforcer la prévention de d'améliorer
le dépistage est de généraliser le
dépistage de certains cancers
d'améliorer la qualité des soins qui
sont offerts aux malades de d'améliorer
les conditions de vie et les droits des
malades du cancer
et puis de coordonner la recherche pour
en obtenir les meilleurs résultats
un plan global dans lequel le malade est
désormais partie prenante
il devra systématiquement être informé
sur sa maladie et sur les différentes
possibilités de traitement la prise de
conscience que maintenant le cancer
n'est plus une affaire de médecins c'est
une affaire de couple de partenaires
entre médecins et malades
ça vient des états généraux
du cancer ça vient des états généraux
les malades se sont exprimés ces parties
du sida ça vient maintenant dans les
maladies graves
c'est quelque chose d'irréversible des
attentes que les malades avaient
effectivement largement exprimée au
point des états généraux de la santé
organisée par la ligue contre le cancer
il y a deux ans l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire pour assassinat
après le décès d'un agent de
surveillance chargé du stationnement un
contractuel à paris ce matin c'était
dans le 19e arrondissement un
automobiliste aurait délibérément
heurtés avant de prendre la fuite
alors que l'agent procéder à
l'enlèvement d'un véhicule mal garé
condamnation par un tribunal de créteil
d'un vendeur de cassettes pédophiles à
trois ans de prison
50 acheteurs de ces cassettes ont
également été condamnés à des peines de
un et quinze mois de prison avec sursis
assorties d'amendés de trois à vingt
mille fond c'est un terrifiant record
criminel qui vient d'être battu par un
médecin anglais à rolle chipman
il aurait tué au moins quinze de ses
patientes et la police le soupçonne
d'avoir assassiné une centaine d'autres
en chip man vient d'être condamné à la
prison à vie mais il y ait encore 136
dossiers de meurtres qui sont ouverts à
son encontre
correspondance à londres benoît duquesne
j'espère qu'ils pourront maintenant nous
consacrer uniquement à la mémoire de ma
mère elle qui était une femme si
heureuse pleine d'énergie et d'amour
elle nous manque c'est la fin d'un
procès marathon 57 jours d'audience 6
jours de délibéré 300 témoins entendus
l'angleterre se réveille avec le plus
grand tueur en série qu'elle ait jamais
connue et peut-être le plus grand de
tous les temps
harold schipman paisible médecin
généraliste de 54 ans marié père de
quatre enfants est reconnu coupable de
15 meurtres est soupçonné dans 146
autres cas shipman ou l'histoire d'une
enfance tranquille dans une banlieue de
nottingham un père routier une mère au
foyer
rien que de très ordinaire jusqu'au jour
où cette mère meurt d'un cancer à auld à
17 ans il assiste aux visites du médecin
et au piqûre de morphine pour soulager
ses douleurs
pour brian master criminologue qui a
assisté au procès c'est sans doute là
qu'il faut chercher la vocation de sheep
man il sera médecin mais tueurs ce qui
est important c'est pas tellement le
pouvoir
donner la mort mais le plaisir d'y
assister pour lui c'est très important
d'être là au moment du passage de la vie
à la mort un passage qui se faisait
parfois ici dans son propre cabinet en
toute confiance
un coup d'injections massives de
morphine jusqu'au jour où schipman
lui-même ce trail il falsifie
grossièrement le testament d'une de ses
victimes
sa fille s'en aperçoit on exhume le
premier corps le docteur schipman laisse
alors la place à un psychopathe
nécrophile et la sphère fait tellement
de bruit ici en angleterre que le
ministre de la santé tout à l'heure au
parlement a annoncé l'ouverture d'une
enquête indépendante pour essayer de
savoir comment pendant toutes ces années
le docteur schipman avait pu échapper au
contrôle des autorités médicales et même
de la police tente il est vrai que
chacun ici se demande quel crédit il
peut apporter à son bon vieux médecin de
famille plusieurs nominations dans le
théâtre et les spectacles viennent
d'être annoncées par la ministre la
culture francis huster au théâtre du
rond point paris catherine anne au
théâtre de l'est parisien dominique
pitoiset et josé montalvo le chorégraphe
au théâtre national de chaillot les
mémoires d'un paysan bas breton publié
aux éditions anr sont en train de
réaliser un beau succès d'édition feu
sont quelque 400 pages rassemblant les
notes écrites dans la deuxième moitié du
19e siècle par le fils d'un journalier
agricole breton de la région de quimper
cet homme a beaucoup voyagé du mexique
jusqu'à la crimée avant de terminer sa
vie misérablement mais il a laissé 26
cahier de 100 pages que l'on vient de
retrouver ce qui a permis ce livre
unique et passionnant
olivier cieux gabriel camilla nous le
présente 26 modeste cahier d'écolier
recouvert d'une écriture appliquée sans
rature toute une vie celle de jean marie
béguigné un paysan finistériens à
l'itinéraire exceptionnel
tour à tour mendiants soldats fermiers
débitants de tabac et dont les souvenirs
sont aujourd'hui un livre à succès et
pourtant ces deux mille six cents pages
décapante et est tombé dans l'oubli
avant d'être retrouvée presque par
hasard chez son arrière petit fils
et c'était dommage car loin des visions
romantiques d'un âge d'or de la bretagne
rurale
ces mémoires sont un témoignage
exceptionnel sur la misère de l'époque
le journal d'un écorché vif
foncièrement républicain et anticlérical
je ferai tout mon possible pour le
triomphe des républicains car les nobles
et les jésuites nous ramènerait cinq
siècles en arrière au temps où les
paysans les ouvriers est estimé à 17
degrés au-dessous des bêtes de somme et
des chiens dédiée n'est ni pourra être
ni rudy fils d'un bhl paysans il m'aura
dans la misère
mais au fil de ses pérégrinations lui
qui au départ ne parlait que breton
avait appris à lire et écrire en
français
c'est ce qui fait la force de son
témoignage des lignées et par une
existence extraordinaire la voix de ses
contres et c'est pareil que quand il est
homme de troupe et qui fait les les
campagnes napoléoniennes on ne trouve
pas de témoignages d'hommes de troupe
c'est toujours les officiers qui
écrivent sait jamais les hommes de
troupe d'où l'intérêt considérable de
ses mémoires parce que c'est la voix des
sans voix
dans cette librairie quimpéroise le
livre figure en bonne place au rayon des
meilleures ventes
soixante dix mille exemplaires à ce jour
un chiffre exceptionnel qui va permettre
à harkat et d'entreprendre la
publication d autres textes laissés par
jean-marie des guignet car sa critique
radicale de la société traditionnelle ne
vaut pas que pour la bretagne
il aurait pu être tout aussi bien
normand ou auvergnat et c'est peut-être
ce qui explique un succès qui dépasse
les frontières d'une région n'arrivant
la fin de cette émission je rappelle
acuité concerne en autriche des
négociations ont eu lieu tout au long de
cette journée avec jorg haider le
président du parti libéral d'extrême
droite que l'on voit ici mais aussi avec
monsieur tout seul le président du parti
conservateur monsieur climat et le pas
avec mon siège du président du parti du
président de la république monsieur les
styles pour tenter de trouver une
solution à la formation du gouvernement
ne triche formation déjà condamné par
l'europe si l'extrême droite entre
erding était notre invité à rappeler que
c'est le droit moral de l'europe de
porter une appréciation sur ce qui se
passe en autriche
dans quelques instants retrouvez patrice
drevet pour la météo 23h05 la vie à
l'endroit présenté par mireille dumas à
0 heures 50 le journal avec florence
duprat à 1h20 il y aura le ciné club
avec le très beau film d'ingmar bergman
cris et chuchotements demain à 7h50 dans
les 4 vérités gérard morin recevra le
professeur michel marty cancérologue si
tu lui stavrou 6 à 13 heures vous
trouverez carole gaessler à demain 20h
bonsoir merci